good morning believe nation today's
message is focused on happiness over to
you zendaya
well the best thing I've learned and
advice I could give me my younger self
is really to focus on happiness you know
happiness is a key because there's so
many people that you see either in this
industry or just in life in general that
are going through their days and may
have everything they could ever want but
they're not happy you know so you have
to focus on what makes you happy and
make decisions in your career in your
life that make you happy and so I've
been trying to do that and it's working
you know and and saying no to things
that are negative and saying no to
things that don't you don't want to do
you know so I'm I think that that's my
biggest piece of advice something I do
or I try to do every day is I try to
make someone whether it be my team or my
life or whatever just happy or make try
to make them feel good or feel
comfortable or feel loved whatever it
may be it could be the littlest thing it
could be just saying oh you look really
pretty today or it could be something
even smaller than that it's something
bigger than that you know it doesn't
really matter but it's just making a
conscious effort to make someone feel
good and that could be a stranger or it
could be your mom you know I think this
is a really important message
I don't think entrepreneurs focus on
happiness enough and I think when I am
most creative when I'm in the zone the
most when I'm working on things that
have the biggest returns it's when I'm
happiest I thrive when I'm happy I do my
best work when I'm happy and so I think
it's important to try to be there as
much as possible now the next question
which becomes harder is well how do you
how do you stay happy how do you get
happen how do you stay there and we've
done entire videos just on that but I
think the answer ultimately comes down
to self-acceptance I think the more that
you love yourself and accept yourself
for who you are and not just accepted to
be like yeah yeah well that's all I'm
ever gonna be
but like love yourself I love these
things about myself
this thing that everybody thinks I'm
crazy about like he's crazy cuz he does
that I love that about myself when you
love yourself then what happens is you
stop doing things because of other
people you stop chasing something
because you want to look good for
somebody else because you want to just
beat that person because you want to
please somebody else the less you care
about other people's opinions and
judgments and expectations the less you
care about that stuff and the more you
focus on yourself and what makes you
come alive and what you want to do and
be willing to shield yourself it doesn't
have to be in an arrogant way like you
don't have to put somebody down when
they have an expectations of you right
when they think you should be doing that
and you say well who are you to tell me
that right you don't have to put them
down but else it doesn't have to impact
you you know I love that you guys all
have different opinions on what I should
do and what I should wear and where I
should go and what my goal should be I
love that always for the most part comes
from a place of love it's like what you
would do or if you were in my position
but at the same time I'm not doing this
because you guys want me to I'm doing
the thing that I want to do that makes
me happy and when you love yourself when
you accept yourself and love yourself
then it makes you happier at least that
makes me happier and so I'd strongly
encourage you to examine the work that
you're doing why are you taking on this
project or going down that path who are
you doing it for are you doing it just
for somebody else are you doing it
because you want to look bad in front of
somebody else are you doing it because
you're just trying to you know boost
your ego up or to have a great picture
that you can post on Facebook or
Instagram are doing it because your
parents want you to do it or because
you're just trying to beat somebody else
or are you doing it because you had the
fire to do it you're doing it because
you need to express yourself and you got
to let this thing come out I'd strongly
encourage you to examine the reasons why
you're doing the work and if too many of
your projects are out we're focused
instead of
I love doing this then you're not really
gonna be happy and you're not really
gonna create something amazing so flip
the switch make for yourself and be
happy so the question today today is are
you happy are you happy with the work
that you're doing leave in the comments
below I'm gonna join in the discussion I
also want to give a quick shout out to
Luc Marcus John Kroger thank you so much
for picking up a cup of my book your one
word it really really really really
means a lot to me so thank you guys
again for watching I believe in you I
hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is and I'll
see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot of espresso for those of
you who want to learn a little bit more
about how to focus on happiness here are
some extra bonus clips hope you enjoy
you want to fleshy things until you know
you grow older you know it's an adult
and you'll be able to understand
yourself a little bit more I learned
that the things that make me happy you
know I learned that you know that really
money really told make me I'm learning
that now you know that's not really my
arm my peace of mind having money you
know that some I learned this year your
support I learned that you know jury and
all that stuff for me to make that me
and when you learn that you'll be able
to grow grow more as a person you know
what makes me happy is really
challenging myself in knowing that I
defeated my school you know and took
myself to the next level a better person
what's success anyway
its success about making the most money
no not no money for the most part turns
people into jerks if you if you do
become rich to the University
fundraising and Development Office will
certainly want to stay in touch with you
and if you give enough money you'll get
your name on a plaque above the dirty
laundry bin here in the men's locker
room but that still doesn't make you a
great person and it definitely doesn't
mean anyone will like you I mean don't
get me wrong as I mentioned before
you're never gonna feel richer than when
you've paid off those credit cards and
student loans but after that money tends
to be pretty own fulfilling almost all
the people I know have made a lot of
money they turned into that guy
all right well you know the guy who pops
his collar and if he and if it were up
to him and you're wearing two shirts he
could pop both collars that's the guy so
how will we know when we've done it
right what's the ultimate measure of
success then what's the key to success
well in my experience quite simply
success is happiness it all comes down
to happiness and I definitely don't mean
that happiness that you feel when the
Gophers take over on downs in their own
red zone as great as that feels I mean
that happiness that quite literally
fills your lungs the kind of happiness
that makes a noise it announces its
arrival with a deep inhale on a deep
exhale that happiness you know that
happiness right that happiness is
success because it turns out happy
people get jobs happy people create
happy people win happy people fall in
love and raise families they lead and
change the world
happy people get what they want because
often happy people were the ones who
realized they don't actually need much
more than they already have and they
appreciate what they've got happy people
are contagious she's worried about the
rent
okay she's a single mother about her
kids you know and then you can do about
the rent and worrying about it I think
I'll get you to rent presents and
happiness gets you rent money can't make
you happy but happy can make you money
so be happy go out in the world with
your story the guy in the shanty house
he rolls over in the morning
meditates goes out into the world it's
like damn I'm gonna have to get some
bread and water before the whole [ __ ] go
down before I get back in that bed but
the meantime be nice to all my neighbors
in the shanty village everybody is
suffering and what everyone else calls
extreme poverty but he's happy he didn't
have a poverty mindset no is he worried
about that bread and water they don't
give me some month Brett I don't worry
about that so now I'm that dude he walks
out smiling confident comfortable he
gets what he needs he says the Yogananda
would say God will provide but really
your God just working to get and it will
shows up he gets his bread and water he
makes everybody happy everybody makes
him happy lays in the bed next
he wakes up he's got it you know you
know 36 billion dollars in the bank he
gets up the stock box builds up he says
Oh get some coke get some alcohol gets
happy so excited I'm exploding you're
making more money more money morning
oh she crashed oh she's more cocaine
more alcohol oh [ __ ] up up up under his
hot gold up and down and he dies at 40
the shanty house guy lives in a hunt
lived to 100 if he had the other guy's
diet not to diet el the guy took but the
other guy's opportunity for have a
greater diet the guy in the shanty Ozma
would have made a hut in 20 but you know
made 100 this guy died at 40 that's the
reality of all you know our happiness is
up to us you know our relationship with
the world is up to us our anxiety is
controlled or given to us by us what
Seneca is saying is he's not and all the
Stokes they're not saying like you can't
be wealthy you can't be successful you
can't go out and do things what they're
saying is that you can't you can't be
dependent on these things like he's
saying like wealth is nice if you have
it but if you make your personal
happiness dependent on having this money
that's bad because it's not in your
control right the economy could melt
down at any moment or your house could
burn down or you could lose your job and
if you have equated wealth with personal
happiness now your personal happiness is
outside of your control and so stoicism
is about control in that sense how do
you how do you make the distinction
between externals and internals and
focus most of your energy on internals
having externals is nice but sort of
what what they would say is that
understand that they are yours in trust
which means that they could leave you at
any moment and a lot of the stoic
exercises are sort of about practicing
not having those things so Seneca was
famous he one day a month he would
practice being poor
so you'd wear like crappy clothes and if
you would like not eat at his house and
he would sleep outside and he would just
I mean it's even more now like a
metaphor than anything else but the idea
is like we're so afraid of these things
so we don't think about them and
therefore we're not prepared
and then it makes them much scarier and
we dread them that much more even though
if you looked at it really objectively
it's really not that bad I had a dream
to come to Barcelona but afterwards I'm
thinking maybe you should keep your
dream instead of making it come through
because that dream could almost not
almost could have not destroy me but
make it difficult for me and first six
months fantastic I had a fantastic time
I had a very good relationship with
Guardiola I wanted to learn the
Barcelona the way of playing it went
good for six months after that something
happened that I still don't have answers
for which which maybe I will never know
I mean if somebody has a problem with me
should come to me we resolve it whatever
the problem is like a man because was it
was ridiculous you don't talk to the
player the player is looking for answers
at that moment I was not happier and I
said I have to choose either I stay win
everything but I will not be happy or I
go to somewhere else and that is what
that I went to milind my joy kept back
for playing football did a good job
I wonder the Scudetto immediately among
the supercoppa everybody was happy and
they were like appreciating me for
playing there